When Tenrehte was first getting off the ground,
we entered our prototype PICOwatt
into a competition associated with CES,
Consumer Electronics Show,
the world's biggest industry trade show.
And we built the prototype in my dad's basement.
We had no idea if it was actually going to work
on stage at a live demo for CES judges.
And the product, when we flew it to Arizona,
it wasn't working right off the bat.
We were fixing software
and changing it at the last minute.
And I got a sinus infection on the plane,
and I had to get up on stage
and do the demo anyway.
And I was holding on to my phone
to demo that the PICOwatt
would turn lights on and off on stage,
and I had no idea if it was going to work or not,
but I was hoping that it was.
And when I pressed on,
the light turned on,
and the product worked,
and it was just this serendipitous moment
between me and my partner Carlos
when the product worked live when it had to
in front of a huge stage,
you know, with a huge audience
and tons of judges.
And I think it was at that moment
I really knew we weren't just playing around
with a start-up company,
that we could actually do this.
We could build products.
We could get it out there
and that people would appreciate what we were doing.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.